[Musique]
le london bridge anglais la porte de
brandebourg allemande et même la mairie
de rambouillet la ressemblance est
frappante et impressionne les visiteurs
c'était vraiment très rigolo c'est de
voir la réaction des gens quand ils
passent la porte ils font tous la même
chose c'est-à-dire ils ont des yeux
vraiment écarquillés et c'est vrai que
c'est impressionnant pour tout le monde
de voir ce qu'ils ont réussi à faire la
lanterne souhaité une exposition ludique
et interactive
elle a été séduite par la proposition du
centre cap là
l'exposition a été montée à l'aide des
scolaires de la ville et s'est ouverte
le 5 décembre
un vrai succès environ 300 visiteurs se
rendent au pôle culturel chaque samedi
que ça mais par la tour de pise est pas
mal comment elle tient quoi le fait de
qu'elle tienne sans colle aussi en plus
de la visite les enfants peuvent
s'essayer à leur propre construction
avec des ateliers gratuits animés par
des membres du centre cap là c'est bien
et respecte bien et des fois ça un peu
dur mais j'arrive bien au vu du succès
du monde en cap là la lanterne recherche
déjà une nouvelle exposition pour sa
saison 2019 2020 au moins une exposition
dans le style ça peut être un style
artistique différent mais ce que je veux
dire c'est avec un objectif de
participation de la population et
et vraiment un objectif de
de rassembler les différents agents fait
notamment les enfants et les jeunes
vous avez jusqu'au 26 janvier pour
reconnaître la sagrada familia de
barcelone
et encore le port de copenhague
[Musique]